[Music]
my name is alex holman and i play tenor
smith corona with the boston typewriter
orchestra the boston hybrid orchestra is
an ensemble for typewriter and voice
some of us have musical backgrounds some
of us don't several of our members play
in bands currently i
haven't touched much of anything except
for a typewriter since playing the
trombone in high school we play a wide
variety of typewriters from some small
portable models all the way up to some
relatively large desk models
a lot of what we do in building up songs
is really exploring what different
sounds we can get out of the typewriter
and how we can incorporate them into a
song
for example you have the the key makes
it
a basic clack sound um but then you have
the the shift that
moves a lot of the mechanics and makes
somewhat of a bass sound then you also
have the the roller that gets a uh
get sort of a mechanical ratchet sound
to it um and then all of them we can
work with the uh
the carriage return for like the
you know the standard swoopy sound to it
as our name suggests the boston
typewriter orchestra is boston based but
we've actually played all over new
england
most of the typewriters are 50 60 70
years old
usually in our hands we see two to three
years of lifespan we beat on them pretty
hard
my fingers have hurt when we started out
in 2004 we were we were a bunch of guys
getting together and kind of banging on
typewriters we get that we're kind of
weird it's a little bit of a wacky idea
but we've discovered that this makes
some legitimate music and it can be a
real serious endeavor we have true songs
that come together and people seem to
really enjoy them and as long as we
still are entertaining people we're
going to stay out there typing
[Applause]
you